I've been eating tacos my whole life I'm
pretty sure I'm like 48 percent taco at
this point I love tacos because they're
the food that doesn't give up on you and
they follow the rules of a hotdog but
they have the energy of a sandwich
they're very much like pizza but better
I prepared for today by eating a whole
head of lettuce as I saw in a
documentary that that's what you're
supposed to do so I did how sweet will
it be to win no maybe retire move to the
south of France I've always wanted to do
woodworking my strategy is psychological
warfare I'm going to eat these tacos in
such an attractive manner everyone else
will be stunned hey guys I'm Raina Huang
I'm also known as Marino's crazy and I'm
a competitor eater oh boy
I ate 40 street tacos in 20 minutes I
also ate a burger with 50 patties in it
I had a 20 pound ramen pool and I
absolutely love tacos so I am ready to
eat and I am really really hungry right
now
this is the tiny taco eating contest
[Music]
[Music]
you made such a huge debt yes I think I
may have eaten 50 already I'm gonna say
no papa
but good energy though we're not just
killing it over here this is amazing
you know the real burner it's not a lot
of lime sauce if you laughs I'm hitting
that wall how though seriously huh Wow
come with it I mean I'll just listen
help yourself it doesn't even look like
a ate any of them they pack a lot of
flavor for like a tiny taco like wow I
ate ten and a half tacos today eight
fifteen tacos and I'm pretty proud of
that
I ate twenty-two and a half tacos I'm a
little disappointed in myself I don't
know I guess I'll just give up that
south of France dream it was so silly
anyway I ate $65 they were really
delicious so that definitely helped me
eat it a lot faster
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]